>>> OVERNIGHT, A TEXAS SHERIFF
HAS OPENED AN INSTIGATION INTO
HOW 48 VENEZUELAN MIGS, LEGAL,
WERE FWN FROM HIS STATE TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
HE SAID THEY WERE TAKEN THERE
UNDER SUSPICIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES
AND HOOD-WINKED.
AND NOW DeSANTIS IS TAKING
CREDIT FOR THE FLIGHTS.
LET'S GO BACK TO GLORIA.
SHE JOINS US WITH MORE.
THAT SHERIFF IN TEXAS CLAIMS,
WHO OPENED THIS INVESTIGATION,
THAT THIS WAS DONE FOR A PHOTO
OP.
HE'S ALLEGED THAT LOCAL LAWS
WERE BROKEN, POTENTIALLY FEDERAL
LAWS.
YOU COULD EXPLAIN THAT?
>> YEAH, POPPY.
BEAR COUNTY SHERIFF JAVIER
SALAZAR ANNOUNCED THIS
INVESTIGATION.
HE SAID THAT PEOPLE LURED THESE
MIGRANTS IN SAN ANTONIO,
EVENTUALLY TO FLORIDA AND THEN
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THAT IS HOW HE BELIEVES SOME OF
THE THESE PEOPLE ENDED UP THERE.
HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT HE IS
OPENING UP AN INVESTIGATION INTO
EXACTLY WHAT WENT ON HERE.
VESTING POSSIBLE CRIMINALITY
ATTACHED TO ALL OF THIS.
HE WAS ALSO VERY CRITICAL OF THE
PEOPLE HE BELIEVES WERE
ALLEGEDLY INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THIS SAYING HE BELIEVES THAT
THEY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THESE
MIGRANTS WHO WERE HERE
DESPERATELY LOOKING FOR HELP.
AND ALL OF THIS WILL BE
CONSIDERED AS HE OPENS UP THAT
INVESTIGATION.
LISTEN TO THE SHERIFF DESCRIBING
WHAT HE BELIEVES WENT ON HERE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE
PREYED UPON.
SOMEBODY CAME FROM OUT OF STATE,
PREYED UPON THESE PEOPLE, LURED
THEM WITH PROMISES OF A BETTER
LIFE, WHICH IS WHAT THEY WERE
ABSOLUTELY LOOKING FOR.
AND HOOD-WINKED INTO MAKING THIS
TRIP TO FLORIDA AND THEN ON
WARDS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD FOR
WHAT I BELIEVE TO BE NOTHING
MORE THAN POLITICAL POSTURING.
>> NOW JUST FOR CONTEXT HERE, WE
SHOULD MENTION THAT SHERIFF
SALAZAR IS A DEMOCRAT AND HE WAS
ACTUALLY ASKED ABOUT THAT
YESTERDAY, ABOUT THE POLITICAL
DYNAMICS OF ALL OF THIS.
HE CLARIFIED THAT HE'S ACTUALLY
NOT ON THE BALLOT AND HE SAID
THAT THIS WAS REALLY JUST AN
ISSUE OF RIGHT AND WRONG AND AN
ISSUE THAT HAS PUT HUMAN BEINGS
IN THE MIDDLE AND HE ACCUSED
OTHER POLITICIANS OF TRYING TO
SCORE POLITICAL POINTS.
TO THAT END A SPOKESPERSON FOR
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS HAS NOW
ISSUED A RESPONSE SAYING, QUOTE,
MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN MORE THAN
WILL TO LEAVE THEIR COUNTY AFTER
BEING ABANDONED AND HOMELESS AND
LEFT TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
FLORIDA GAVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEEK GREENER PASTURES IN A
SANCTUARY JURISDICTION THAT
OFFERED GREATER RESOURCES FOR
THEM AS WE EXPECTED.
OF COURSE, WE KNOW FROM THE
REPORTING THAT NOT EVERYONE WHO
WENT TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
ACTUALLY EVEN KNEW WHERE THEY
WERE GOING SO THIS IDEA THAT
PEOPLE WERE GIVING CONSENT OR
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING IS
PART OF THE INVESTIGATION GOING
FORWARD.
POPPY AND JIM.
>> GLORIA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR EXPLAINING THAT TO OUR
VIEWERS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS FOR
REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO LISTEN TO
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND THEN A FEW
FACTS ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> THEY ALL SIGNED CONSENT FORMS
TO GO.
AND THEN THE VENDOR THAT IS
DOING THIS FOR FLORIDA PROVIDED
THEM WITH A PACKET THAT HAD A
MAP OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD, IT HAD
THE NUMBERS FOR DIFFERENT
SERVICES ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
SO IT WAS CLEARLY VOLUNTARY AND
ALL OF THE OTHER NONSENSE YOU'RE
HEARING IS JUST NOT TRUE.
AND WHY WON'T THEY WANT TO GO,
GIVEN WHERE THEY WERE.
>> SO, ALANA, JUST A FEW FACTS
THAT ARE BEING ALLEGED BY THE
ATTORNEYS FOR SOME OF THESE
MIGRANTS, INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT THEY SAY THAT THEIR CLIENTS
WERE MISLED BY BEING TOLD THERE
COULD BE CASH, HOUSING, WORK
OPPORTUNITIES, TRAVEL ASSISTANCE
ON THE OTHER SIDE WHEN THEY
ARRIVED THERE.
ALSO FAILING TO MENTION THAT
THESE BENEFITS ARE THINGS THAT
ARE GUARANTEED TO REFUGEES THAT
GET REFUGEE STATUS OUTSIDE OF
THE U.S., NOT ASYLUM-SEEKERS WHO
COME HERE SEEKING ASYLUM
BEFORE -- BEFORE A JUDGE AND
ALSO THE PAMPHLETS SAYING THEY
WERE FROM THE OFFICE OF REFUGEE
AND MIGRANTS.
THAT OFFICE SAID THEY DON'T MAKE
THESE PAMPHLETS.
SO WHO IS THE TELLING THE TRUTH
HERE.
>> I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT,
POPPY.
AND AXIOS SPOKE WITH MANY OF THE
LAWYERS WHO WERE HELPING
REPRESENT SOME OF THE MIGRANTS
THAT WERE TRANSFERRED TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
AND THEY TOLD US THAT A LOT OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE MISLED.
SOME OF THEM THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO BOSTON.
SOME THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
NEW YORK CITY.
AND WERE OFFERED UP TO EIGHT
MONTHS OF CASH ASSISTANCE AND
OTHER THINGS THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD BE GETTING AND THEY
DIDN'T.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN WHAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IS SAYING AND
WHAT REPRESENTS AND THESE
MIGRANTS ARE SAYING AS WELL AND
I THINK THAT HE IS HAVE IS GOING
TO TRY TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
AND IT IS VERY PROBLEMATIC.
I SPOKE WITH MANY LAWMAKERS ON
CAPITOL HILL, MANY OF WHO
REPRESENT BORDER DISTRICTS AND
THEY SAID THE BIG PROBLEM WITH
THIS, EVEN WORSE THAN WHAT WE'VE
SEEN, WHAT THEY'VE SEEN IN THEIR
WORDS, GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT AND
GOVERNOR DUCEY IN ARIZONA, THEY
SAID THAT THE IDEA OF NOT
TELLING THESE PEOPLE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING, NOT ASKING THEM
IF THEY WANTED TO GO IS REALLY
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS DID AND WHAT
SOME OF THE OTHER GOVERNORS HAVE
DONE.
>> AND THEY SAY THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE THEY WERE GOING AND WE'VE
SIGNED CONSENT FORMS BEFORE
WITHOUT READING THEM.
I HAVE TO IMAGINE IF THERE IS A
PRACTICAL IMPLICATION AS WELL.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU CLICKED
ON THE I AGREE WITHOUT KNOWING
MORE.
AND THERE IS A LAW, SET ASIDE
FOR A MOMENT, FROM A POLITICAL
STAND POINT THIS IS PUTTING INTO
THE PUBLIC AN ISSUE THAT
REPUBLICANS TO SEE THEIR
ADVANTAGE IN THE MIDTERMS AND
TRYING TO KEEP IN THE PUBLIC EYE
FOR SOMETIMES AT NUMBERS HAVE
GONE UP.
IS THERE ANY DATA TO INDICATE
WHETHER THIS IS A WINNING ISSUE
FOR REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS.
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY DATA YET.
I'M SURE THERE ARE POLLSTERS
WORKING ON THIS.
AT WUNT POIN I DID SPEAK WITH
PEOPLE LIKE SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
AND JOHN CORNYN WHO DEFENDED THE
IDEA.
CORNYN SAYING IT WAS A TERRIFIC
IDEA TO THURST THIS BACK INTO
THE NATIONAL SPOTLIGHT.
RUBIO SAID IT IS NOT THE BURDEN
OF THE DIFFERENT CITY AND
STATES, IT THE BURDEN OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT FLORIDA IN
PARTICULAR, A LOT OF VENEZUELANS
AND CUBAN AMERICANS THAT ARE IN
FLORIDA, REALLY DISGRUNTLED AND
FURIOUS REALLY WITH WHAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS DID.
AND THAT IS A KEY VOTING BLOCK
THAT I KNOW REPUBLICANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE TRIED TO COURT
AND COULD BE DANGEROUS FOR
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, PARTICULARLY
AS MANY OF THESE IF NOT ALL OF
THESE MIGRANTS W